let's bring in Dan Shaughnessy the
columnist for the Boston Globe Sixers
winning last night series now shifts to
Boston for Game five Dan in Philadelphia
Celtics finally lose what surprised you
last night
well I think that you know the coach
made a good adjustment as the Connell
you know that that was a good thing to
do and it's kind of predictable 300 I
mean truthfully everybody knows the
Celtics really didn't deserve to be up
300 I mean I guess they did deserve it
but Billy had a 22 point lead in Game
two and then made numerous stupid
mistakes down the stretch of regulation
and overtime in game three so there they
are Celtics sitting at a at a 300 lead
Vegas has ranked the Sixers ahead in
every game going in the Sixers were
favored all four games including by nine
points in Game three the first game back
here so and they're favored again
tomorrow night
so biggest loves the Sixers they are
deemed to be the better team they're
down 3-1 and I they're not going to win
but this makes a little bit more
interesting are they the better team
well I think if you drew it up on paper
and then talked about you know in the
abstracts maybe but as a team know
clearly they're you know Celtics even
though they're equally young and Tatum
hasn't played the playoffs till this
year but the Celtics did have that
experience last year of getting to the
Conference Finals they played all year
without Haywood that played a month or
two without Irving and it's just the
coach does a great job and I think that
the Celtics are a better team at this
point in the Sixers and I think they'll
close it out tomorrow night when Kyrie
went down if I would have told you this
team could be advancing to the Eastern
Conference Finals what would you have
thought yeah yeah we Kyrie went down it
was like this became an audition for
2019 it was like the playoffs great
let's see what they can do we'll take a
look at everybody and we'll give you
some idea what you're looking at next
year I had no expectation that they were
going to get to the NBA Finals which you
know they certainly have a chance they
there they're going to get to the
Conference Finals they going to play
LeBron again I think LeBron sent home
I think four times in this century
and he's done a lot of people home and
the way they're playing now it's amazing
but what's Boston has done is beyond all
expectations one serving went down I
mean the expectations were there even
when Haywood went down they won 16 in a
row out of the gate and they were the
flavor of the month of the NBA at that
time but that kind of went away with the
you know Tyson they lost ice and in
Irving was a was a big blow to them and
they've been able to you know to hang in
there and and play some of their best
ball in these playoffs
when did you realize Brad Stevens was
going to be as great as he's been and
was there a was there sort of a moment
there you know in the last couple years
where it just sort of have you know
perspective change I know on the
national stage now people are looking at
him and realizing you know hey the
Butler guys doing pretty well in Boston
but you're there every day was there a
moment well he's got that that level I
mean he's gene Hackman and Hoosiers
without the criminal record you know
he's just this guy that knows basketball
knows how to handle the voice and gets
the most out of them they're all in the
right place to where they're supposed to
be they maxed out on everybody and and
the play calling Dan after timeouts
that's that's you know that kind of
became legendary in Game three and then
guys from Butler were saying yeah we did
that in your skill in the tournament or
whatever so I think that you know we've
kind of seen it evolve and each year has
gotten a little bit better and that's
why this year is interesting because
last year they got to the Conference
Finals well how much better can you do
than that so well that would be getting
to the NBA Finals maybe they can do that
but yeah his his stock is so high right
now I think you could bring Amazon to
Boston that's the last job look at you
you got you got Hoosiers in there and
did you use these in your column just
pre cycling it for my audience well
thank you though I appreciate that and
also Danny Ainge the job that he's done
as well I mean this is our back Ian that
you know some of the moves that he's
going you know and I know we don't
necessarily he doesn't get mentioned
there as much or you know it's a great
GM like you should but and you know
credit goes to him yeah I really you
know one of the good parts about him in
our town he doesn't take the heat he
doesn't read
act when he gets criticized which is
which is frequent believe it or not but
if you just look back that deal with
with Tatum and folks now I mean that's
that's that's moving into the category
of rügen Robert Parish and Kevin McHale
but Jill Barry Carol I mean now because
they they got the guy they wanted who's
the better guy he's he's scoring 20
points every night in the playoffs bolt
isn't playing and then they got a pick
on top of that I mean it's just like and
it's been a series of those things I
mean not everything worked out you know
he he drafted Kelly Olynyk instead of
the Greek Creek I mean everybody's got
that on their resume but I think that on
the totality of it is amazing he's got a
really good team and he's you know he's
got a good chance to go to the
Conference Finals without Kyrie Irving
and Gordon Haywood who will be back next
year presumably which means there we
should be looking at these two teams
Philly and Boston for a six seven year
run if if people stay healthy one other
thing here maybe you can help us we
discussed it yesterday Brad Marchand
with this whole licking thing with the
Bruins wait is it is it on purpose is he
crazy like what is going on yeah I love
the player hate the act that's just
there's no place for that I'm surprised
it it played at all in Boston I think
with the coach they have with the
players and in that room Bergeron Chara
they've got to be embarrassed again no
place for that it's just stupid and he's
a wonderful player and he gets under
your skin but that's not there's other
ways to do it and that is not one and I
just I'm glad he goes into the summer
having to realize that no more of that
and really there's got to be no more
that it's just stupid oh one other thing
did people in Boston buy into the
possibility of trading up for Baker
Mayfield with that number two spot if he
was going to be there according to his
agent yeah you know his personality
doesn't seem in line with what they do
here so I don't know and I think that
basically there's the hole in Bill we
trust thing outside of Malcolm Butler
that philosophy generally plays well to
the crowd back there so it builds a
bundling picks and figuring this year's
draft not that good we'll go next year
and trade in threes and fours for next
year and stuff like that people just go
along with it and say that's okay
it isn't weird that in after a Super
Bowl which they couldn't get the other
team off the field they lost a game
which they did not punt
they didn't they didn't pick any
defensive players up high safe travels
to N thanks for joining us as always
take it for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]